I don't think I've actually mentioned
this story inside there was this event
and they got James Khan Alan sugar
Richard Branson to come and do keynote
speaker I was like I really want to be
part of it but obviously I didn't know
how I'd get their press passes Etc so
what I did was I emailed owner of the
event and I said hey so I'm this 17 year
old how about the day before I basically
lay out all the chairs and all you do is
you give me a backstage pass he would
say yeah okay cool a lot of people
underestimate the power of both naivety
and youth people would have seen that
all right he can't get a backstage pass
so just go oh well I guess I can't but
like I'm actually going to figure out
what I can bring to the table which is
just like energy and time and I think
for a lot of young people they almost do
not realize how many superpowers they
have in terms of just like energy time
and naivety